Cyclone marker has made landfall along
the coasts of Bangladesh and Myanmar
hundreds of thousands of people have
been evacuated to safer areas as strong
winds and rainfall battle the coastline
of the two countries nearly a million
rohingya refugees living in camps at
Cox's Bazaar in Bangladesh are in the
storm's rejected path Aid agencies say
they are preparing for a major emergency
response let's get the latest from
tanvira choudhary who joins us from
Cox's Bazaar tanvi bring us up to speed
with the latest the Cyclone has been
approaching fast it's landed in fact
what's been happening
okay as you can see behind me the wind
speed has really geared up since last
half an hour now according to the
Bangladesh Med office it could hit
somewhere between now and local time 4
P.M which will be 10 GMT that's been
saying that from 6 GMT to 10 GT is a
targeted time the tracker is showing its
moving mode towards Myanmar Coastline
rather than the Bangladesh technof area
but it will get some of the thrust here
we have a danger signal number 10 which
is the highest uh that's 20 category uh
five hurricane so it's it's really one
of the strongest Cyclone we have seen in
recent decade now most of the people
have been evacuated to the naval Center
well at least over 200 people have been
evacuated Emergency Medical Teams
thousands of volunteers are standby same
in the refugee camp unfortunately the
refugee camp don't have concrete shelter
most of the people are living in a
bamboo blue hearts with tarpaulin fee of
the government offices and mosque and
other are built with concrete but
there's no shelter and it's too late to
evacuate that many number of people
nearly a million refugees half of them
children and in this part between
chottagram which is about nearly 200
kilometers from here and the entire Cox
Bazaar belt is exposed to this cycle
mainly where we are as technov is the
last time Bangladesh bordering Myanmar
so this is the area they're expecting to
hit I'm 20 kilometers from the town in
front of me is a hill behind that there
are a lot of coastal Villages fisherman
they were here about three hours back
walking just looking around and now most
of them are gone they clearly know the
danger now the Prime Minister sheikhasin
ourselves is monitoring the cyclone and
they said they will do their best to
tackle with whatever the after effect
maybe after the Cyclone thanks for
looking pretty bad as the wind goes
10v thank you tanvi thank you so much
for the update Andre chandri live there
at Cox's Bazaar where Cyclone mocha has
a hit Bangladesh and Myanmar as we've
said earlier with a million refugees at
Bangladesh's Cox's in the storm's path
we'll keep you up to date with the
latest with tanvir chandri our
correspondent who's on the ground